hey guys i'm here with nidhi robinson
artists displaying here at the london
chess classic we see a lot of her work
here featuring the different players
which player do you like to draw the
most Bobby Fischer is some of this very
carrots for I've done many pictures of
him some for commissions and and some
that I picked out myself and is just
very interesting interesting kind of
features makes a very good image very
good picture how about players from the
London task pathak from the London chess
classic I've done several new ones and
vision and is one that I've done several
of and I have a new one here with me
today I've got Aronian who's made
absolutely beautiful beautiful picture
as well really great great intense look
and I've also got Magnus Carlsen I've
done I've done a few Magnus Carlsen and
we've got a new one on the table as well
what kind of expressions do you like to
capture the mast um well what I like to
do is to actually watch video footage of
the of the players because it gives me a
sense of what they're like the kind of
poses they make the sort of expressions
they have and I find that the best way
to try and find the right image so what
i do is i watch the video and i will
pause it and and get the image that i
think most is most character for
fantastic i'll shout out to kevin then
well thanks guys back to you in st.
Louis here with Nettie Robinson at the
London test classic